we're like oh he was Austin attendant
yeah buh-bye probably for like four
years he thought he was a dick yeah so
that you had you had a meeting with
Spike Jonze right in New York yeah so
that was so yeah so they were like so we
were waiting for the offer
whenever I'd met with Nick why didn't
fell his idea it was to make it series
and then I was like well where's the
offer they're like well spike has a few
questions like what the [ __ ] does Spike
TV have to do with this I thought it was
by saying like yes Spike Jonze whoa wait
spike [ __ ] joke yeah they're
like hey some questions gonna send it by
email I'm like no I'll fly to New York
to meet with Spike Jonze that'll love
Spike Jonze yeah so Brandon and I both
flew ourselves out and I'm dying oh my
god and then went in and pitched for
like two and a half hours so about a
quarter the way through the meeting
spike was like great I love it so what
do we need us do we need a showrunner is
that what we need yeah and I was like no
I'm gonna do it he goes crazy and
there's about the next three-quarters of
meeting convincing him that I was the
only guy who could run the show and so
I'd already I had episodes written I
didn't tell him that yeah I had the
world beat out at the characters pretty
much dialed in and just in the tone
specifically like I just figured for the
money we had we weren't gonna get a
better showrunner really yeah to kind of
like go out and try to grab somebody and
get them excited about Diplo and excited
about the world like he was just
something that kind of came through me
and there's all that momentum I was like
yeah and I'd been writing for a while so
um like been ghost writing for myself
for lots I just thought you know what
[ __ ] it man let's let's just try it yeah
and also it's like here's you wanna you
want to get into that world of being a
showrunner a producer or whatnot and
this it's yell in your lap yeah I feel
like you're a good dude and it happens
for people that are good you know you
just think things just happen work out I
have to study Diplo and study the world
of EDM yeah yeah for sure
what's EDM electronic dance EDM was a
[ __ ] DJ Naoko yeah
I saw no Colette in Atlanta I've told
the story before huh tell it again
please
I was in a hotel and inoko what whatever
to me and I saw I knew I Kaley knew who
he was he picked me up like I was a
little baby and he's a skinny juicy
Japanese yeah yes Jeff he's half though
right yes easy yeah there's some white
oh yeah yeah and he picked me up like a
little baby and then you know we took a
photo on a somebody was very nice but I
don't know anything about no that's not
the story or the story was you were so
kind of happy you're starstruck a little
bit because you pretend you don't know
his name but you know exactly who Steve
is and so you saw him I didn't see him
at the airport I saw him at the hotel
all right the picture was yes that's the
part of story that's the fun I lie a lot
yeah I lie a lot and make up things all
right so let's let's go back let's go
let's get to the truth of the story the
truth of the story is this he then took
the photograph and wanted to brag to me
about meeting Steve Aoki stop stop
that's where that's where it is that's
number one
I I was right I vaguely knew who he was
but I knew who he was okay I saw him at
the thing I did at first it wasn't like
oh there's Steve a Yoko
all right so then when he goes it's
Steve Aoki and I and I go that I knew
that she in her Vegas days would go and
see her shows yeah and like [ __ ]
rubber [ __ ] while watching his shows
because she had a little crush price
right but did you meet him in an airport
or a it was in a hotel okay guys then
exchanged numbers we do it exchange
numbers yeah and then what happened I
don't remember
what was it what happened was you were
trying to brag to me that you had just
met Steve Aoki yeah and then you instead
of sending me the text oh that's on
coal's you sent it to see yes and then
you had to apologize and say oh my god I
was bragging to ride into my girlfriend
then I met Steve Aoki the steerer and
all that stuff but I sent it to him
that's [ __ ] right and then I had to go
I'm so sorry I was for my girlfriend
that that was so embarrassing I blocked
it out babe you know you know his dad
found it Benihana right what this is
favorite place on earth so now you're
even worn buried like Benihana I did
until I realized that everything tasted
like ginger like and legends like the
lobster taste the same as the chicken
and this day I did ginger or maybe I
went to maybe they maybe the one I went
to in Encino wasn't exactly the Encino
really good one though unseen yeah maybe
I just maybe I had an AA bad chef
[Music]